en la siguiente serie de vídeos vamos a
predecir la forma de moléculas illones
usando la teoría de repulsión de pares
de electrones de valencia llamada p esp
r por sus siglas en inglés también
conocida como r p esp de r&b que dice
que los electrones como están cargados
negativamente se repelen entre sí y
cuando se encuentran alrededor de un
átomo central la repulsión provoca que
la molécula o el ión adopte una forma en
particular el primer paso para predecir
la forma o geometría de una molécula o
ion es dibujar la estructura de puntos
de luís para mostrar los electrones de
valencia entonces dibujemos la
estructura de puntos de lewis para el b
l 2 el berilio se encuentra en el grupo
2 de la tabla periódica así que tiene 2
electrones de valencia y el cloro se
encuentra en el grupo 7 pero como
tenemos 2 2 por 7 es igual a 14 y 14 más
2 nos da un total de 16 electrones de
valencia que debemos colocar en la
estructura nuestro átomo central debe
ser el átomo menos electro negativo en
este caso es el veril unido a dos claros
ahí está ya hemos puesto cuatro
electrones de valencia aquí tenemos dos
y aquí otros dos entonces 16 menos 4 aún
nos falta colocar 12 electrones de
valencia primero vamos a llenar el
octeto de los átomos terminales los
claros observen que cada cloro ya está
rodeado por
los electrones así que cada uno necesita
6 electrones más para completar su
objeto ya colocamos los 12 electrones
hemos terminado quizá algunos se
pregunten por qué no muestro algunos de
estos pares de electrones libres
compartiendo se con el berilio para
completar su octeto bueno es por la
carga forma asignemos la carga formal a
nuestro berilio recuerden que cada
enlace covalente consiste en dos
electrones y si queremos saber la carga
formal necesitamos pensar en el número
de electrones de valencia que existen en
el átomo libre para el berilio son dos
así que tenemos dos electrones y ahora
pensemos en el átomo de la molécula si
observamos el enlace covalente uno de
los electrones se comparte con este
cloro y el otro electrón se comparte con
éste
y que está rodeado por sus dos
electrones de valencia y 2 menos
2 la carga formal es igual a 0
así que al analizar la carga formal
podemos saber cuando hemos terminado de
dibujar la estructura de puntos el
berilio solo tiene 2 electrones de
valencia y no necesariamente tiene que
cumplir con la regla del octeto así que
puede tener menos de 8 electrones voy a
redibujar la molécula para verla mejor
pongamos los pares de electrones libres
alrededor del cloro
ahora contemos el número de nubes
electrónicas que rodean al átomo central
que las podemos ver como regiones de
densidad electrónica y como los
electrones se repelen entre sí esas
regiones de densidad electrónica esas
nubes quieren estar lo más lejos que
puedan entre ellas entonces analicemos
nuestra molécula alrededor del átomo
central tenemos estos electrones que
forman un enlace así que esta es una
nube electrónica y de este lado tenemos
otra nube electrónica así que tenemos
dos nubes electrónicas que se encuentran
muy lejos entre ellas así que la
geometría de las nubes electrónicas
alrededor del átomo central es una
geometría lineal y como no tenemos
ningún par de electrones libres en el
átomo central la geometría de la
molécula también es lineal
línea y podemos decir que el ángulo de
enlace entre un cloro y el berilio y el
enlace entre el berilio y el otro cloro
es de 180 grados es una línea recta
hagamos otro ejemplo tenemos co2 dióxido
de carbono el carbono tiene 4 electrones
de valencia y el oxígeno tiene 6 como
tenemos 2 oxígenos 6 por 2 es igual a 12
y 12 más 4 tenemos 16 electrones de
valencia en total que colocaremos en
nuestra estructura de puntos recuerde el
átomo menos electro negativo es el que
ponemos al centro así que ponemos al
carbón y está unido a 2 oxígenos por
sólo hemos dibujado 4 electrones de
valencia
aquí tenemos 2 y 2 entonces 16 menos 4
es igual a 12 nos falta colocar 12
electrones de valencia y los podemos
poner en nuestros átomos terminales los
oxígenos para completar su octeto cada
uno necesita 6 electrones de valencia
ahora aún no hemos terminado porque el
carbono tiene que cumplir con la regla
del octeto y como aún no tiene una carga
formal igual a 0 podemos completar su
objeto moviendo uno de estos pares de
electrones libres hacia acá para
compartirlos entre el carbono y el
oxígeno y podemos hacer lo mismo con
este par de electrones observen que
ahora tenemos un doble enlace entre el
carbono y los oxígenos
y ahora cada oxígeno tiene dos pares de
electrones libres regresemos a la lista
de pasos ya hicimos el paso 1 dibujar la
estructura de puntos para mostrar los
electrones de valencia después
necesitamos contar el número de nubes
electrónicas alrededor del átomo central
en este caso es el carbón si pensamos en
las regiones de densidad electrónica
alrededor del carbono podemos tomar este
doble enlace como una región de densidad
electrónica aquí tenemos una nube
electrónica y por acá tenemos otra en
total tenemos dos nubes electrónicas que
se repelen entre sí ahora vamos con el
paso 3 predice la geometría de las nubes
electrónicas alrededor del átomo central
bueno las nubes electrónicas quedan en
lados opuestos así que nuevamente la
mole
o la adopta una geometría lineal
entonces la molécula de dióxido de
carbono también es lineal y tiene un
ángulo de enlace de 180 grados y como no
tenemos ningún par de electrones libres
en el átomo central la geometría de la
molécula es completamente lineal
entonces primero dibujamos la estructura
de puntos de lewis y contamos las nubes
electrónicas para predecir la geometría
en el siguiente vídeo
veremos cómo predecir la geometría de
moléculas con tres nubes electrónicas